Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with information about Homeland
Security secretary Jay Johnson and his
Infamous diance with the Islamic Society
of North America it was bad enough that
Johnson recently spoke at the annual
Convention of isna the Islamic Society
of North America which is a group with
demonstrable ties to Hamas and the
Muslim Brotherhood but what he said
there made it even worse first what is
isna according to discover the networks
the Islamic Society of North America was
established in July 1981 by us-based
members of the Muslim Brotherhood with a
background as leaders of the Muslim
Students Association his author and
terrorism expert Steve Emerson puts it
isna grew out of the Muslim Students
Association which was also founded by
Brotherhood members indeed Muslim
brothers would dominate is's leader ship
throughout the society's early
years the investigative project on
terrorism adds that in a 2008 Court
filing isna and its affiliate the North
American Islamic trust did not deny
evidence of their ties to Hamas and the
Brotherhood but simply argued that the
evidence was old nonetheless Jay Johnson
chose to speak at is's convention in
September 2016 first he assured the
crowd tonight I will not talk to you
about counterterrorism M then the theme
of Johnson's address was that Muslims in
the US were unfairly targeted for
discrimination and harassment and that
he was on their side his principal
argument that this unsubstantiated
targeting is unfair was nothing but his
denial of the painfully obvious link
between Islam and terrorism Johnson said
you have heard us before multiple
audiences of different political Stripes
refuse to bend to the political pressure
to call terrorism Islamic extremism we
know that is though it claims the banner
of Islam occupies no part of your
religion which is founded on peace he
knows that how does he know that having
declared that terrorism had nothing to
do with Islam Johnson was then able to
dismiss concern about Islam in the US as
just another manifestation of the ugly
Prejudice that he said had made life
difficult for other immigrant groups in
the past he told the crowd your story is
an American story told over and over
again generation after generation of
waves of people who struggle for seek
and will eventually win your share of
the American dream know the history of
this country and you will know that
whether it's Catholic Americans Jewish
Americans Mormon Americans Irish
Americans italian-americans Japanese
Americans African-Americans Hispanic
Americans or Muslim Americans This will
be
true yes let's remember you remember
when Catholic Americans Jewish Americans
Mormon Americans Irish Americans
italian-americans Japanese Americans
African-Americans and Hispanic Americans
flew those planes into towers and bombed
the Boston Marathon and murdered 13
Americans in Cold Blood at Fort Hood and
four in Chattanooga 15 in San Bernardino
49 in Orlando and tried to commit mass
murder in Garland Texas and in so many
other places you remember those global
Terror organizations made up of
Catholics Jews Mormons Irish and so on
committing acts of violence around the
globe and threatening the imminent
conquest of the US and the rest of the
Free
World the Obama administration's
solicitude flows entirely one way toward
Muslims as victims of discrimination
which according to the administration's
own hate crime statistics is a false and
inaccurate claim anyway meanwhile the
Jihad advances as do Islamic supremacist
attempts to assert Sharia Norms over
American Norms Johnson of course had
nothing to say about such things or
about the unaccountable phenomenon of so
many Muslims in the US adhering to the
version of Islam that Johnson assures us
is
unlam and then at the same isna
convention we Johnson's fellow speakers
among them was Yasir khadi who has
taught that Muslims can freely take the
lives and property of non-muslims in
Jihad khad has said the life and
property of a mushrik that is one who
worships others besides Allah holds no
value in the state of jihad which means
if they don't say Allah that is there is
no God but Allah their lives and
property are Hal that is they can be
taken by Muslims Dalia mahad spoke as
well Obama's former adviser on Muslim
Affairs once appeared on a British
television show aired by the pro- Sharia
group hisb T where she said Sharia is
not well understood and Islam as a faith
is not well understood how have we all
misunderstood Islam well she said we've
Associated it with maximum criminal
punishments and laws that to many people
seem unequal to women the Western of
sharia she said was oversimplified she
claimed that most Muslim women worldwide
associate Islam and Sharia with gender
justice another speaker was Tariq
Ramadan French journalist Carolyn foray
in her book brother Tariq notes that
Ramadan is quote remaining scrupulously
faithful to the strategy mapped out by
his grandfather who was Muslim
Brotherhood founder Hassan abana a
strategy of Advance stage by stage
toward the imposition of a Islamic law
in the west she explains that he invests
words like law and democracy with subtle
and carefully crafted new definitions
permitting him to engage in an
apparently inoffensive discourse while
remaining faithful to an eminently
islamist message and without having to
lie overtly at least not in his eyes
also at isna was the celebrated Kizer
Khan and tus has recorded that Kizer
Khan has worked at Hogan lovel's LLP
according to the Washington Free Beacon
the man whom the mainstream media styles
as David to Donald Trump's Goliath Hogan
lovel's LLP another us firm hired by the
Saudis is registered to work for the
Royal Embassy of Saudi Arabia through
2016 disclosers show Robert Kyle a
lobbyist from The Firm has bundled
$5,850 for Clinton's campaign the Saudi
government supplied the Clinton
foundation with Millions the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia has given between 10 and 25
million to the foundation while friends
of Saudi Arabia have contributed between
1 and 5
million now why is the secretary of the
Department of Homeland Security
appearing with this Saudi funded
politically motivated individual and
others with these ties to Hamas and the
Muslim Brotherhood and open advocacy of
jihad and Sharia the answer is obvious
because he shares their agenda I'm
Robert Spencer